Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast is
just checking in.
Are you?
What's going on?
It's just fucking global warming.
Awesome.
Or what?
Jesus Christ,
the summer just keeps going.
It's incredible.
Um,
the Golden Age,
the golden age of global warming.
Enjoy it before the sea levels rise up.
MMM.
By your waterfront property in West Virginia soon.
Sorry,
I don't want to go with all gloom and doom here.
Um,
it is,
uh,
12:46 AM Thursday.
Uh,
so I have gone 56 days.
All right.
56 days.
Two months.
Sorry,
two months.
No fucking booze.
And 56.
Now what does the number 56 mean to you?
All you baseball fans out there.
October playoff baseball,
56.
Jolton Joe Dimaggio's unbeatable hit record,
hit for 56 games in a row.
And it's,
I think it's very poignant that I bring up a great Yankee when those fucking
cops just came back against the,
uh,
Cleveland Indians.
And uh,
I have to tell you,
it was a red sox fan.
The Yankees are common and they're going to be good for a while.
They've got a bunch of,
you know what I love about the Yankees?
Is there a fucking team?
You know what I mean?
I fucking hate that they're going to be good,
but I've got to acknowledge it.
They're fucking good.
Um,
poor fucking Cleveland.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Jesus Christ.
[inaudible]
oh Jesus.
Oh,
that's an old Jesus right there.
Up Two games to Nanaya decided when one more,
you know,
fucking do it.
Fucking comedy of errors.
I didn't see the game four,
I guess they fucked up a bunch of errors and then they just,
you know,
the fucking guy in left field,
that's the single turn into a double than they overthink fucking alligator arm
of fucking cutoff and the guys scratch this was a fucking shit show.
However,
the only thing I don't like about the fucking,
by the way,
Brett gardeners at bat legendary at bat,
their shortstop there.
I don't know if I'm going to say his name.
Raise a DD.
Gregarious.
I have no idea.
Two huge fucking home runs.
My only,
my only question mark,
if I can go sports radio right now.
Are you buying or are you selling?
I don't know about Chapman is the closer,
you know,
I know he closed the fucking game.
That was great for him.
I know he wanted for the cubs last year,
but I don't know.
I don't think you got to fucking strong closer when he walks the first guy and
you already have somebody else up in the bullpen.
Maybe I'm spoiled.
After all those years when I watched Marianna Rivera,
nobody fucking got,
it's fucking,
Marianna were very,
that gave it,
the game's tied.
The game's over.
Except in 2004 of clothes.
Of course,
I'll bail you cunt.
Um,
that was impressive.
So now they're going to play the Houston Astros.
A franchise without an identity.
I don't know what it is about them.
I was just talking to a j Lo head,
you know,
giving them my condolences.
I congratulate Versie my teams out of it.
I'm not a cunt,
right?
Well,
I am,
but not that big of a cut.
Um,
I was just at what the fuck?
Why are the Astros' so not exciting?
Is it to uniforms?
Yeah.
Maybe I'm just an old guy.
When they were in the fucking national league and they had,
I don't know what you would call those fucking uniforms,
those things with his shit.
They sorta had the,
uh,
the gay bar flag,
you know,
gay friendly fucking flag.
They were flying those colors really progressive way back in the late seventies.
They played on the National League.
So it was all hitting run.
They had the astro turf de ja Jr Richards.
They had hope say cruise Enos Cabell you remember that fucking team way back
when?
I don't think that they've been fucking exciting ever since.
It's some point they decided to have those fucking bland uniforms.
It's like dark color.
Yeah.
You know what it looks like they did uniform.
It's the uniform equivalent to when you go on a diet,
you know,
you have your first little fucking chest pains and they,
the doctor goes,
look,
and we'll tell you way now.
He didn't take off 30 pounds.
Need to cut all the salt and sugar out of your diet.
Right?
And you're like,
oh fuck.
And you just sitting there eating lettuce,
staring across somebody.
If somebody went to dinner with their eating the chicken palm,
their order in bread and you're just sitting there with your fucking salad and
the protein no bigger than the size of the palm of your hand.
They have the uniform version of that low level of excitement.
Um,
I have no,
I don't know shit about the Astros'.
Other than that,
they had an unbelievable year.
So,
uh,
I fucking love October baseball.
Um,
my fucking Red Sox Los,
we deserve to lose.
What are you going to do?
A,
we'll see what we do in the off season.
A congratulations to the Astros.
Definitely were the better team and a,
I missed all the Dodgers series and I saw the highlights tonight of,
uh,
of the cubs in nationals.
Jesus Christ.
That fucking grand slam is brutal.
You know,
it's weird.
Is the cubs lost for so long?
I still felt bad for him.
I forgot that they won the world series last year,
but I was just,
I'm so used to feeling bad for cubs fans.
I actually felt bad when that guy hit the home run.
And by the way,
can anybody explain,
and I,
this is always bugged me about Wrigley field is that fucking fence that just
juts out that little basket,
you know,
that gives the warning track power guy a fucking home run.
What are they going to take that thing down?
I don't understand that thing.
It hangs out into the field of play.
It's not a fucking,
oh,
it is a home run.
The little,
the little fence there.
What are we playing?
Fucking tee ball,
take the goddamn basket.
Whatever the fuck that is.
Um,
reminds me way back in the day when against the Yankees first,
the URLs,
when that kid reached over and grabbed the home run instantly became a fucking
hero with all Yankee fans who then I'll then turn around and fucking call the
fucking red socks.
I mean,
the,
the Patriots cheaters,
it's Hilarious,
but everybody does it.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
look at this big story out here in Hollywood.
The big scandal have the Weinstein,
right?
First of all,
dude,
I mean,
what a display of power to finish in a potted plant and then have the nerve to
call the person the next day saying,
hey,
you know,
I had a great time.
I mean that's out of your fucking mind and I don't get these fucking people,
uh,
where everything,
but I'm going to go to rehab.
Yeah.
How do you go to Rehab to stop you for preventing a woman leaving a room,
taking your dick out and coming on a fern.
Do they have rehab?
I didn't know that.
What do you in there for?
Oh,
you know,
I uh,
I fucking blocked an exit and just on a plant.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
Me Too.
I guess we're going to be buddies here.
Huh?
You know when they just in this wing of the rehab with this no potted plants,
they got buddies outside the fucking window.
Tried to sneak fucking plants in form.
That is the most bizarre fucking story.
But,
um,
that's not what I want to talk about here.
You know what I mean?
Where they fucking sit in there going to all,
I love when they said all all of men in Hollywood kept silent.
It's like everybody did and they weren't acting like Harvey Weinstein couldn't
ruin the career of a guy.
That guy up until four days ago could take your career,
wanted up right in front of you and throw it in the gutter and you were done.
You were fucking done.
You're talking about a guy,
whoever allegedly could block a woman from leaving a room
and then calming on a plan and then fuck it.
Does the follow up call like,
like the,
they went to dinner and a movie and they had a lovely time.
That's the level of power this guy had.
Human being should not have that level of power by the way.
Cause man or woman,
they,
they do not handle it well.
Um,
but anyways,
let's get back to far as like,
you know,
being able to see both sides.
The fence here,
sports fans that just like,
you know,
that's obviously holding.
And then if the holding called,
doesn't it go against you?
It's like,
oh no,
no fucking great.
Call Greg Non Call Fox News Day.
We're going off on fucking Harvey Weinstein and all Hollywood now underhanded
and blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
But when Trump was grabbing the pussies,
they got nothing,
right?
And then fucking CNN,
it's the same fucking way Trump grabs the fucking pussies.
They're all fucking over.
Harvey Weinstein does what he does.
This isn't a time to fucking politicize this thing.
They're both so fucking full of shit.
And they're going to judge all the Hollywood on Harvey Weinstein.
Right?
The same way the Liberals Judge all Republicans on Donald Trump.
I don't know anybody.
Uh,
watch is either one of those channels.
However,
I will say this cause I don't watch Fox News that often.
I don't really watch CNN,
but I will say at least see it and it looks,
it looks professional.
I'm not saying it is all it is,
but I'm not saying it's obviously not ridiculously biased.
They both are.
But what is Fox News looks like?
It looks like fucking Wsp k TV 38 back in the day when they'd go in between
periods and that little bullshit said,
I don't know.
What about Fox News?
It's like they got to put more money into it.
Everybody looks sweaty,
you know,
I don't understand it.
Um,
but anyways,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Uh,
so now they're going back into everybody's life.
They go back into somebody's eye.
You did this back in 2000.
Here's my thing.
All these guys and now going to have to apologize for all this shit they did
ever deadly back into the fucking 90.
So whatever my question is,
is when is the,
when is it going to even out?
I would love to see some gold digging whores come on and apologize and be like,
yeah,
hey,
sorry,
I took your house and add a couple of kids with you and said that I loved you
when I really didn't.
Uh,
I shouldn't have done that and then prevented you from seeing those kids that
you had with me.
That half look like me and you now know that I never really loved you.
And,
uh,
I'm sorry for that and banging the new guy in this house that you bought.
And now I'm also not going to,
you know,
have my new boyfriend ever move in or marry me because then my payments from you
and the alimony will stop.
I want to apologize for that.
My behavior was completely unacceptable
just to balance it out.
Listen,
if you're new to this podcast,
um,
one of the mainstays of this podcast is that I'm a,
I'm a,
I'm a contrarion count.
All right?
So if you're,
if you're new to it,
you know,
I don't know.
This first 11 minutes is what you can expect for the rest of this.
Um,
anyways,
I am in Atlanta,
Georgia right now.
Uh,
I got a,
uh,
I've got a small part in a big movie.
I mean,
that's my career.
That's my,
that's my fucking wheelhouse.
I love it.
You know,
all I want to do is paratroop in for a couple of fucking days,
have a good time,
you know,
get to watch the real fucking actors do that goddamn thing.
I always feel like I won a contest when I do a movie.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Hey,
you want to be in a movie?
Oh boy.
Oh boy do I.
Um,
so I'm going to be here for the next,
uh,
the next couple of weeks,
you know,
missing my family,
like fucking crazy.
Uh,
I'm hoping,
uh,
trying to work something out where I can bring them in so I don't lose my
fucking mind out here.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I was actually so fucking lonely and depressed last night.
Um,
I mean obviously succeeded to do a movie,
just missing my family that I walked by a liquor store and I saw this bottle of
booze in there in the window and I was like,
uh,
am I going to buy that and finish all of it?
And fortunately I walked past it and I went down to the laughing skull comedy
club,
uh,
went up on stage,
thank you to them for putting me on stage.
And I went up there and I'm going to say I kind of eat my balls.
It was a very,
a give and take,
a lot more.
Whatever's worse,
but w a lot more worse.
A lot more give or a lot more to,
I don't know what it was,
but it was a
hotel.
It was a rough one.
Okay.
Um,
then,
anyway,
so now I'm out of here.
I got to figure out what the fuck I'm going to do.
I went to trader Joe's,
I bought some healthy fucking food.
You know,
all this shit's healthy,
but they still have a frozen food aisle,
so I don't get that.
You know what I mean?
They still have fucking cereal.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's that part of a balanced breakfast isn't cereal.
I don't,
can you even see what the fuck is cereal.
I've just thought about that.
Like what is in a cheerio?
I bought these brand fucking things.
I don't know what they are
like,
can you make cereal?
I bet there's some somebody on youtube,
homemade cereal.
I'm going to look that up.
I bet to be.
I'm going to go out and let me say on the first person who ever fucking Google
this home.
Fucking feds are going to knock on the Goddamn door right now.
Homemade cereal.
Does anybody like serial enough to fucking do directions?
Okay.
Preheat your oven to 275 degrees.
I don't know about you,
but I'm already out.
I get either open a box and pour it and it's done.
Or I can go preheat my oven to 275 degrees for my friends around the world.
That's 135 degrees Celsius.
Um,
in a large bowl mix.
Oats,
wheat,
germ,
wheat germ.
What?
I lose that in and wheat brand.
Oh my God.
If you can actually take the time to make cereal,
this is what you're going in a medium bowl blend.
Brown sugar,
vegetable oil,
honey and water mixing.
Vanilla extract is you making here?
Cinnamon.
Nutmeg sounds like you,
it a pie and salt big for 45 minutes in a preheated oven,
stirring every 15 minutes or until lightly brown.
Hey Eddie,
you're 20 minutes fucking later than you usually.
Are you usually only an hour late for work?
Where the fuck you been?
Oh,
you know what I'm saying?
All my always cha making breakfast.
What the fuck did you make?
Homemade cereal.
Hey Daddy,
do me a favor.
Why don't you fucking go punch out and get the fuck out of here?
You're fired.
How do you make corn flakes flakes?
Saudi make cocoa puffs.
They actually had this shit.
How to make cinnamon toast crunch quarter cup of whole wheat flour.
Pastry flour.
Who the fucking time to do this quarter cup of all purpose flour.
Baking Soda,
cinnamon.
All right.
Wait a fucking minute
if we're going to go this far right?
Yeah.
How do you spell Fritos?
Homemade fritos.
Alright.
Heat the oven to 375 degrees.
Cut to pieces of parchment one the same size is a beacon baking sheet and set
aside in a small bowl.
Whisk together the cornmeal and the salt please.
One sheet of parchment.
Okay.
Am I going to do this?
Can you imagine if you fuck it made a homemade fritos and people like what the
full weight of fuck did you get these freedom?
Oh,
I made it myself though.
Homemade.
Are you on house arrest?
Who the fuck has time to do this shit?
Fucking asshole.
You make it homemade,
you know,
how did you make your own trans fats?
You fucking psycho.
Um,
quarter thought.
Who the fuck would have thought that you could do something like that?
It says a fucking great country.
Um,
I've heard people make it.
Do you hear that fucking Graland side?
What is that?
Yeah,
I shut off the fucking air con.
I fucking hate air conditioning.
It's so overused.
Air conditioning is like that person at a party who just won't shut the fuck up,
you know?
Oh,
you know what they said that about,
I was watching,
you know the B e t a rapid wards there,
hip hop awards and I'm,
I'm watching all this shit.
And they had the guy from two live crew,
they were giving him like a lifetime achievement award and it was fucking
hilarious.
He was up there dressed like he just got a doctorate
and then afterwards he does all this music and it's all owe me so horny.
All that shit.
I'm not saying I don't like that fucking music,
but I mean,
Jesus Christ,
he had like a bow tie on and his whole suit and everything,
it looked like it's a fucking elder statesman.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
I dunno,
I was
talking to my wife about it,
but I don't know shit about hip hop,
but this whole fucking thing where everybody is drinking that shit,
that lean,
whatever the hell it is,
and everybody sounds,
even if they're not fucking wasted,
they sound like they're waste drives me up the wall.
I just listened to it.
It's like,
you know,
when you go to a party and there's somebody way more fucked up than you were
just like,
dude,
I can't talk to you.
I got,
how did I got to get out of this?
Um,
that's what it sounded like.
That one dude lost all that fucking wait,
man.
The guy usually takes his shirt off when he was fat,
he took his shirt off.
Now he's skinny or,
and he has his clothes on,
which probably means he's still getting the skin removed or whatever.
You know,
it's funny.
All the weight that he lost.
He still weighs more than all of the Migos
put together.
Even with their jewelry on,
I'm sorry,
I've just been my first day on the movies tomorrow,
so I've just been sitting here and fucking watching TV and a waiting to work.
So I've just been watching,
mmm.
Just been watching all of this shit and uh,
listening to music and stuff.
Dude,
I know,
I'm like fucking over 10 years late on this thing,
but I am an old guy is,
um,
I've just been listening to the first to Mars Volta albums and I gotta tell you,
John Theodore is a fucking genius drummer.
That,
what is it?
How do you say this,
Sarah Eyes?
I don't want to say anything.
V.
I s C r a any drummers out there.
You got to listen to that fucking song and you've got to learn how to play it.
You can't be a drummer at listen to that and not want to at least that open and
drum groove.
I don't know what the fuck he's doing on the breakdown in the end,
but it's one of the sickest.
Okay.
Fucking drum grooves I've ever heard in my life.
And you listened to what the guitar is doing.
Most people would have just played with the guitar and the way he fucking plays
around it.
And one of my favorite things is does not have this snare on two and four.
It's,
and it's still just fucking not only fucking rocks,
it propels this fucking song.
I think I've listened to the song 200 times
and the last fucking week and it's still giving me chills.
It's fucking unreal.
And I,
my drum teacher a long time ago told me to get into this band much sugar and I
listened to it and I just,
it was too advanced.
I couldn't,
I couldn't hear what was,
it was just too much shit to be listened to.
But because I've been listening to Mars Volta and they're crazy shit.
I actually went back cause I was scrolling through looking for Mars Volta and I,
and I had this much sugar album for the longest time.
And I went back and listened to it and I think I'm finally starting to like,
I always knew it was amazing,
but now I actually am like fucking into it.
Um,
I just keep us in that first song.
I'm baby step in my way into it.
This music is way advanced for my fucking limited fucking musical abilities.
But that first song Stanger,
just the drumming on that,
the whole fucking thing is unbelievable.
So,
uh,
I'd just been,
that's what I've been doing.
I haven't been Busan.
I've been watching old twilight zones.
I've been listening to though.
There's all this fucking music and uh,
I dunno,
I went out tonight to his cigar bar.
That's my one vice that I have left.
That's all I got left.
Um,
and I went out and ordered my fucking club soda and a lime.
I got to tell you,
the minute I actually feel,
you know,
walk out,
I'm not shit faced.
It's Nice,
you know?
Yeah.
Bill,
that'd be boozed every fucking day.
People find that nice after what I will.
All right then.
All right.
I haven't been able to watch any of the hockey.
Fucking,
I know the Bruins are one and two.
We got crushed by the ass tonight.
Six to three.
And I'm actually debating on Saturday because I'm going out of my mind,
uh,
missing my family.
I'm actually debating the Tennessee volunteers have a home game.
I'm actually debating,
it's a three hour drive.
I know they're not good this year,
but that's such a legendary stadium.
They are home.
I live on the other side of the country.
It's three hours.
I can drive up their scalp,
a fucking ticket.
Watch him play the South Carolina.
Gamecocks Nice Sec.
Match up.
I get to fucking go to that state.
I think I'm going to do it.
What else am I gonna do?
Sit here alone in this fucking hotel room.
Missing my Kiddo,
you know?
Um,
anyway,
so let's get into the,
uh,
I think I'm going to do it.
Fuck it.
That'll be my 20th,
my 20th,
um,
college football team that I've seen.
I've seen some big ones though,
will be my fifth or sixth SEC team that I've seen a home game.
I've seen Texas a and M,
Lsu,
Alabama,
Georgia,
Florida,
and then Tennessee.
I mean,
as far as the big ones I'd have left.
I'd have Auburn,
Ole Miss,
Mississippi state,
and fucking Arkansas.
You know,
no disrespect to,
uh,
Vanderbilt was,
who's left?
Vanderbilt,
Kentucky and Missouri,
Missouri.
Like,
you know,
I feel like the SCC is like,
they're rebound conference,
you know,
they still want to be in the big 12,
but the fucking university of Texas came up with their own,
I dunno if their own yes.
Network,
their own Nesson whatever the fuck they did.
I don't understand why everybody else just didn't do the same thing.
Um,
but anyways,
I think I'm going to do it anyway though.
Isn't enough enough with the fucking babbling here?
Oh,
a little bit of advertising here.
All right.
A burrito dough,
[inaudible] bills all the fucking loan to do,
do,
do beyond these.
Mandy's valve it up against my bone.
Make it my junk.
Feel really fucking Nice.
Uh,
get us steel chrome.
If you got some lights or some fucking crabs down in your fucking under and you
know,
maybe that's a way to get rid of crabs.
That's like,
that's how fucking nice to me and disarm it.
Literally,
it just makes them,
they fall asleep and they let go your pubes and they fall right off,
down into socks.
That's disgusting.
All right.
Uh,
me [inaudible] you know me undies makes the most comfortable underwear in the
world.
World world.
If underwear is in your thing,
you fucking animal.
We're excited to announce that me undies socks are finally here.
Speaking of animals,
by the way,
I'm calling her right now.
That Yankee Fan at the end of the fucking Cleveland series,
when they cut to those two Yankee fans,
the guy on the left,
when he was clapping,
somebody's going to turn that into something.
I mean,
how,
how unathletic are you that you can't even clap
if to see when they teach like a chimp on a clap of fucking chimpanzee.
Clap better than this guy in the fucking look on his face.
I don't know what was going on with that guy.
I hope he doesn't help.
He's not touched on some level then.
I feel bad.
He did have front row seats.
You never know.
Uh,
anyways,
be ready for work,
play and everything else in between with the new me undies,
socks,
me,
undies,
socks are now available.
Ah,
making your toes fill all nice there.
[inaudible] socks are spun from premium materials.
Just made me think of Rapunzel making their socks the best you can get for your
feet.
Mandy's will be the most comfortable pair of underwear and now socks you'll ever
own.
Jesus Christ.
How the fuck you going to go to work?
If your balls and feet feel that good,
you're going to be nice.
You can be nice to everybody.
Uh,
Mandy's will be the most,
they should've sent a pair of those to the fucking Grinch.
Mandy's will be the most comfortable pair of underwear now socks you will ever
own 100% satisfaction guarantee.
They guarantee you will love your undies and socks or your money back.
Right now.
Me Youngest has an exclusive offer just for our listeners and every other
fucking podcast they advertise on.
You get 20% off your first order and free shipping.
Me undies is so sure you will love their underwear and socks.
They will give you a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Simply order a pair,
and if you don't love it,
get a full refund.
Um,
to get your 20% off the best and softest underwear and socks you'll ever own for
free.
Um,
well free shipping you'll ever own.
Sorry,
free shipping at a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
You got to go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot
com slash park they're not free.
They're 20% off.
Sorry.
For some reason,
the way they put comma a comma always fucks me up.
All right,
next lift everybody.
Lyft knows that their drivers are what keeps them moving.
Well,
obviously you fucking drive people for a living other than the car and the car
can't do shit without a driver.
Uh,
so they will do everything they can to make sure their drivers are happy on
every trip.
Sorry.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that believes in treating it's people better
that I love how all this shade that they're throwing over at fucking Uber during
this lift begin believes that being a ride sharing drivers should be fun.
If you're having a good time.
So are the passengers well,
don't have to good at time.
You fucking up my life in your hands there.
If it choosing,
I ride sharing company to drive for go with the company that treats you better.
Lift lift was the first offer.
INAP tipping.
When you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips are my stomach's growling here.
Being an actor can't eat late at night.
A 100% of the tips drivers will be paid over 200 million in tips.
Since drivers haven't paid over 200 million in tips since the feature was first
introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get pay almost instantly instead of waiting for weeks.
Lyft has taken the guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp device uses color coding to help passengers find the drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips.
What are,
Whoa,
are you drive boards?
Never been easier to give yourself a raise.
Sorry,
I'm doing this one 13 in the morning here.
Now it's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of every 10 Lyft riders get a perfect five star
rating.
So join the ride sharing company that believes in trading.
It's people better.
Go to lift.com/burger today and you can get a $500 new driving bonus.
That's lyft.com/bar
lyft.com/ [inaudible] spelled l,
y.
F.
T.
It's a limited time.
Only terms do apply.
All right.
What am I up to here?
28 and change.
I got to kill another minute and a half.
Um,
actually if I do the drive
up to Knoxville,
Tennessee,
um,
I will pass through one of my favorite and most one of the most underrated
cities in the United States,
Chattanooga,
Tennessee.
I've only been there one time and I had such a fucking great time.
Great Food,
great bars,
just great people.
Just a great fucking great city.
Love that place.
And um,
and Knoxville is another place that had a great fucking time.
Everybody goes to Tennessee,
they all go to Nashville.
They want to go to the grand old fucking Opry.
They want to fucking,
I don't know what the fuck you'll go see some live music and all that shit.
I'm telling you right now,
sorry.
Do not sleep on Chattanooga,
Tennessee.
Do not avoid Knoxville diff.
Fucking great.
I swear to God,
if I wasn't in this God damn business,
I could live in either one of those towns.
Um,
I'm a big fan of that state.
not that I'm shitting on fucking Georgia here cause it's another good time.
Uh,
speaking of which,
I guess the College Hall of fame,
some sort of hall of fames out here.
I might go check that out down the street.
Um,
but that is it.
That is a podcast here.
Oh,
Billy freckles here is,
I got to get my eight hours sleep.
MMM.
And go do my fucking little
what I like to call acting tomorrow.
Uh,
that is it.
It,
was there anything else I wanted to talk about,
like promoting anything coming up?
Oh yeah,
we added a third show and I'm in Austin at Austin city limits now is all excited
that this is the same place where I saw Stevie Ray Vaughan play.
But evidently that's a new one.
However,
it is the same place where I saw Iggy pop with queen of the Queens of the stone
age performed.
So it is legendary and we'd be down there with Dean del Rey and I'm trying to
find out if I can record.
Um,
cause my Madison Square Garden recording did not work.
I fucked up.
They just gave me the recording from the board.
So I am loud as shit and you can barely hear the crowd.
So,
oops.
I Dunno if I'll ever get to do Madison Square Garden against,
so,
oh well I guess it's just a memory.
Um,
but I'm starting to think when I play like these really cool venues like this,
that I'm just gonna record the audio.
I don't know what I'm going to do with it.
I might just start,
you know,
putting out a random like fucking just on vinyl is some shit.
MMM.
You know,
I got to know the guys over there at third man records that's also in Nashville.
Uh,
Jack White's company.
Those guys treated me great.
I did my,
uh,
Carnegie Hall One with those guys.
So maybe who knows,
maybe I could do something with them.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I kinda like the idea that,
cause my act changed so much and I have like a lot of like topical shit.
And I was thinking like,
what if I just,
I don't know,
just start recording all these sets and then maybe I splice it together.
A bunch of different ones.
I don't know.
We'll see what happens.
But it's never bad to have a good recording.
Right.
Am I just spit balling out loud to you guys as if this is fucking entertainment?
I have no idea.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
Uh,
congratulations to Jaromir younger.
You got fucking signed with the Calgary flames.
The man's career continues and I look forward to watching them out there.
I know I made all you guys yawn.
I apologize,
but I don't have time to do this tomorrow.
Uh,
that's it.
You guys have a great day.
A wonderful weekend and
I will talk to you on a Monday and a,
those of you new to this podcast,
we now do a greatest hits from a Thursday gone by.
You can listen to some cool music.
If you have any questions about who did the music,
just tweet at the mm podcast at the podcast.
And uh,
Andrew is really good about posting that type of shit to let you know who it is
cause he plays all the cool music,
you know,
um,
I'm way behind as you can tell.
All right,
I'm just starting to get into Mars Volta.
Okay.
I'm getting into a that people are hoping is going to have a reunion.
I'm just getting into them.
Okay.
All right.
That is it.
Uh,
all right.
Have a great weekend.
I'll talk to you later,
Susan.
[inaudible]
all right.
Hair loss or sex loss bill,
I'm sure you've heard of Propecia.
Heard of it.
I used it.
Yeah,
I used it and the one I ran out of it,
I just had that honest moment with myself and I was just like,
there's no way.
There's not going to be a side effect.
Okay.
There's always this,
there's no way.
There's just no way.
There's no way this thing,
okay,
I'll save my hair but damage my liver.
You know,
what do I need more?
a full head of hair or a functioning fucking liver.
You just,
you know,
you just got to bite the bullet and tr and just turn old just age gracefully.
You know,
I try to keep my hair short.
I tried to offend as little people as I go through the slow process of seeing
what my skull actually looks like.
He goes,
I have a lot of friends audit that say it's sort of works.
Definitely slows down hair loss by doing something.
However,
apparently the drawbacks is no boner.
Oh,
is that right?
I don't know.
I don't know either way on that one.
That's a,
that's some bar from stuff.
I think that that can,
that can happen to some people.
I have no fucking idea.
He said,
so do you choose hair to get sex or choose no hair,
which might mean no sex.
Is this some sort of sick joke by the pharmaceutical companies?
No.
You,
you're fighting nature.
Listen Dude,
I'll tell you right now.
All right,
there's women out there that think a shaved head is sexy.
Not all of them,
but there's enough.
All right,
there's enough out there that you can keep going out.
Bang.
And women,
you know,
some women find a shaved head fucking they lay like it turns them on.
So listen,
this is the great thing about women is they can see beyond what you look like.
Okay?
If you come in there and you got a little swagger and you're funny and you
fucking,
you know,
shaved head shows confidence,
dude.
You're like,
fuck it.
Preemptive strike.
You guys are walking out on me.
Well,
you know what,
I'm kicking you out the door and you take out your clippers.
You know,
I buzzed my head down a few years ago.
I fucking loved it,
man.
I took all the jokes.
When you can't the patient and look and make a wish,
Buh,
Buh and Peters out after a couple of weeks,
you know,
I dunno,
I go back and forth.
I mean,
I go literally from doing,
maybe I'll do the fucking hair transplant to all the way back to all fucking
shave my head again.
I have no idea,
but I gotta be honest with you,
dude.
It doesn't eat.
The vibe you're bringing is going to be way more.
Listen,
do you really want to get with some girl who's with you because you have a
fucking,
a nice big cow lick on top of your fucking head.
And if you didn't have it,
then she wouldn't be with you.
You know,
going bald is like driving a piece of shit car.
It really keeps the whores away from you.
All these fucking idiots with full heads of hair driving around flashy cars.
You see what happens to him.
But what happened to Mel Gibson?
He should've just gone bald,
but he didn't,
he kept fighting it,
doing shit up there,
drove around in a flashy car.
I had to give up my fucking lacquer tickets,
you know,
flipping out,
flipping out.
You know what dude?
Yeah.
Don't take those fucking drugs.
Those drugs have brand new and the side effects that they're talking about,
I'm telling you,
is just the shit that they're letting on to cover their asses.
That they said that there was some side effects.
Okay.
From what I've overheard and bars,
the people on the FDA,
half of them used to work for these pharmaceutical fucking companies.
So they got the nuts running the fucking nuthouse.
All right,
and you're just going to be,
again,
you're going to be a little lab rat if you start taking that shit.
All right?
So I would suggest not doing it.
Let nature take its fucking course and do what I'm doing.
Wait for the cure and I guarantee it ain't gonna come.
So just fucking man up and go bald.
You fucking pussy.
Okay.
Do what I'm doing.
Just slowly let it happen.
A year from now,
I'm going to have fucking hair plugs and I'm going to be performing for
dictators for New Year's Eve,
New Year's Eve.
Ah,
be best friends with Beyonce.
I didn't see my itinerary either.
I didn't know who it was.
I literally use the same excuse for performing for oil man.
[inaudible]
uh,
the past couple of weeks I've been talking about the food down here in New
Orleans,
saint how delicious slash unhealthy it is and how you can't find fucking Kale.
Excuse me.
As I drift more cold water for my fucking scalded tongue.
MMM.
I actually bought a juicer this week to somehow come back all the fried food
that I've been eating and a,
I started drinking that shit that,
that guy and uh,
uh,
fat dead and kind of sick,
whatever the fuck is called,
fat sick and nearly dead.
Just six fatty would dead fucking something,
whatever.
Um,
I've been drinking that shit man.
I gotta tell you something.
It's delicious.
Not only is it delicious,
you crave it after awhile and uh,
yeah,
I think I dropped like four or five pounds.
Good pounds too.
You know the flabby wants.
I was joking on Twitter saying how I was in,
I was in buttoned down shirt shape and I actually want to get into like,
I want to be in sitting down no shirt on shape.
I don't know what,
I don't bill Cosby did a bit on this but
he's so had,
what the fuck happens when you sit down?
You stand up and look sideways and Mary Lake Guy,
you know what?
That isn't bad.
Dare I say it's kind of cute.
Shows that I like the occasional snickers.
Right.
And you sit there pitching it yourself.
Like you're in an old old school,
special k commercial going on.
Right.
That's not that bad.
It's not that bad.
Then you just sit down and like three handfuls of Shit just lands on your
thighs,
you know,
for the life of me,
I can't let,
what is,
what happens.
The hipbones move up to your fucking man tits and everything just gets blown
out.
I have no idea.
But sitting down without a shirt on,
you know,
that's,
that's the truth moment of your fucking physique that you're going to see all
day.
Yeah.
Stop standing up sucking and you got all right.
You want to see,
you want to see the damage you've done.
Maybe you're not ready for
all right.
This is like the ring,
when you looked at that fucking chick's face,
you judges opens up and you land in a fucking walk in closet.
Oh my God.
I don't know what happened to me.
I'm not even that bad a shape.
So I said,
fuck this.
I got a juicer.
And um,
I just did a quick gig up in Chicago,
came right back,
this private thing.
Um,
so I don't know.
I ate halfway decent up there.
I did find a Vegan restaurant,
but then of course they had had some Chicago Pizza.
Um,
so now I came back and I had my little fucking grilled cheese sandwich and
tomato soup.
So now my body is starting to pull me back to the bay,
the dark side.
And that's what I've really learned about trying to stay in shape.
It's all about keeping your brain out in front of your body,
keeping your fucking wits about you.
Like this shit.
It's like food,
you know when they say food is a drug,
I didn't believe him,
but I,
I'm totally convinced of it now.
It's like when you're eating bad,
when you just go on like a three month bender of just eaten bad in your head.
Like,
Oh God,
I gotta stop.
I don't have a fucking cheeseburger.
And you just keep going and then that makes you want cookies and all that type
of shit.
It's the food equivalent to like locking yourself in a Roman just free basing
for three months.
That's what you're doing.
So when I tried to do,
when I'm eating,
eating bad like this,
I just talked to a buddy of mine outside of the business who's trying to lose
some fucking wait.
I was trying to tell him that like,
you gotta keep your head out in front of it and just go like,
I want that,
but I'm going to eat this.
Even in,
in,
in that moment when you're looking at that apple as opposed to that fucking
glorious whatever you're looking at,
right?
Toasted roast beef and cheese with the fucking pickles and the chips and all
that.
The last thing your body's like,
that's fine.
This is what the fuck I want.
And you got to reach for that apple.
You've got to fucking hit that,
that crack pipe instead.
And I'm telling you the second you get to three bites in,
you're like,
oh thank God,
thank God I did that.
And you find,
cause from what I've,
what I've read,
the very little I've read use your body is actually craving nutrition.
You know,
that's why we eat Chinese food.
Like fucking 35 minutes later you're hungry again because your body's still
craving nutrition.
There wasn't like a fucking ounce of it in that shit,
at the risk of getting sued by that entire fucking continent of China
country.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
so that's what I would say.
Okay.
If you could try to do,
that's what I'm trying to do as I'm trying to keep my head out in front of it.
So I got that grilled cheese sandwich and I got to tomato soup and I said,
all right,
I gotta get back on the fucking Green Gumbo here as I'm calling it because I'm
in New Orleans and uh,
that's it.
I'm back on that shit for the last two tomorrow morning.
Wake up and make another one.
Bingo.
Bango I'm trying to do two a day.
Jewson and then one day have on the fucking,
uh,
you know,
a healthy dinner and then I go on the treadmill for a half hour.
There's no fucking way.
You're not going to drop weight.
All right.
So there you go.
So stop doing those stupid ass fad diets.
EA.
It's the fucking corn flakes died.
I DOJ is eat flakes.
They can eat as much as I wanted.
That bullshit veggie eventually.
Yeah,
you don't really,
I think the really,
it really is,
is not even like,
it's not even the fucking diet.
It's the,
once you get to your weight,
what do you do?
Then?
You know,
once you get down to your weight,
at some point you're going to be looking around.
It's like you got out of jail and there's some ice cream right over there.
You were an adult.
You don't have to go,
mom,
can I have some ice cream?
Right?
That's how you become a fat fuck is an adult.
There's no one to say you had enough cookies.
So on,
you got enough booze put on a condom.
It's all on you.
You gotta be your own fucking parent until you get a lady and your life.
Then she starts fucking nagging at you.
Take shoes are on.
Hey,
I give out the rug up.
Fuck you lady.
Where did you become so angry?
Um,
so that would be my advice
when you're just on,
if right now,
if you'll listen to this shit and you're on a bad fucking road.
I'm telling you one of these days in the future,
you're going to wake up,
you're going to be sitting down on the side of your bed.
You're going to glance it to a mirror and you're going to be like,
what the fuck?
What have I done to myself?
You can stand up real quick.
You can try to suck it in and try to deny the truth that you just saw.
You hear that?
That's the steam engine coming back on the fucking racist genocide.
One on one.
MMM.
The fuck am I to,
yeah.
Just make yourself eat an apple or just eat a fucking salad.
You gotta you gotta turn that.
You got to turn the boat around.
Um,
that's what I'm trying to do.
Hmm.
I got to do what?
I fucking went back up to like almost a buck 90 an hour back down to like the
mid one seventies.
I got to,
it's the fucking worst.
Just trying to lose like 15 pounds is the fucking worst.
I can't imagine people who got a got to lose more than that.
So,
uh,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno how this became more of a weight loss podcast.
Um,
but I think it's working though.
This guy actually sent me a letter.
He said,
uh,
podcast success story.
Dear Wilbur,
you sir are a god amongst men.
Ah,
Jesus.
I wish that was true.
He goes,
I used to be a depressed piece of shit.
You're a,
your typical,
the world is against me.
Nobody likes me.
Nobody wants me fucking moron.
That's who I was.
But your advice on stepping back and making fun of every negative annotation I
have.
Is that a word?
Did he write that d type that correctly or am I in boy annotation?
I Dunno not to make you depressed again.
I don't know how to spell.
Um,
he goes,
I have fucking changed my life.
I'm 80 pounds lighter.
I got a great girl and I've gotten two count them two promotions.
You're a comedian.
You're not obligated to be Oprah Maury,
but you're still making a difference.
Thank you,
sir,
for knocking me back into cohesion.
Uh,
you probably make 20 times more than me.
I doubt that Sorority,
the big promotions there.
Um,
but I know,
but I owe you a drink next time I see you.
If you're in Canada or being tamps,
you stay classy,
sir.
Oh,
that's great.
Good for you,
sir.
Look at that.
He turned it around
somehow my negative,
whatever the fuck my shaming,
my fat shame,
my fishing has been working.
Um,
all right,
enough about that shit.
So that's what I'm doing.
I'm drinking the,
I'm,
I'm doing that fat,
sick and nearly dead juicing thing and uh,
it's like all green stuff.
It's Kale,
celery,
a couple of handfuls of parsley,
cucumber,
Zucchini,
and then alignment to take the bitterness out.
And uh,
I got to tell you it's fucking delicious.
I love it.
And um,
I dunno,
I think I'm going to incorporate this in every couple of months.
Just go back to that.
Well,
just juice for like four or five days just so I stay out in front of it just so
I don't have to have a sit down one day and have that fucking beach ball.
I got a thing on my button down shirts.
It's the one,
two third button down.
When that button's starts to look like it's doing the iron cross between both
sides of my shit of my shirt.
That's one of my guy.
He fucking jerk off.
All right.
And then what happens is they lay off the beer and then I just start slamming
whiskey.
Like that's my initial when I've,
we've began our initial descent until our dieting is,
I go from drinking Pale Ales to whiskey.
I really am a freckled mess.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
October 12th,
2009 and uh,
I am in a fantastic fucking mood.
Ah,
isn't that nice?
Isn't that nice when you run into somebody on a Monday and they were in a great
mood rather than the usual country run into what work.
Hey Jerry,
how you doing?
Well,
you know the fucking week,
Yo girl filled with beer butoh weaken care.
Believe patriots loves due to food for 12 Rudy.
Rudy most would would open.
Shut up.
You think I give a fuck about you?
I was just saying hello.
I was being friendly because we were walking in opposite directions.
Pass each other and our eyes happened to meet.
Huh?
That's all I was saying.
No one gives a fuck about your host.
Stupid Day.
So I'm in an awesome mood and I'm going to tell you why because I've been on the
road for six of the last seven weeks tightening up my act the way bill
Belichick's gonna tighten up that Patriots' defense over the year and we'll
challenge for a fucking title
sometime next year,
but it's still a good thing.
I haven't packed it in yet with the Patriots now.
I've been on the road and I was on the road for the last 10 straight days.
Everybody,
do you have any fucking idea what that's like?
Has any,
you ever gone out there?
You have a gun out to Disney world?
What a fuck do people go for it?
10 days.
Oh my God.
I went to Ahca Poco.
It was awesome.
We sat on the beach,
we were tanning.
We didn't do anything.
We dressed like,
who is,
who was we just like absolutely.
Absolutely,
totally.
100% who is,
we didn't pay for a drink.
I had no pubic hair.
I barely had a bikini bottom on.
I had this island guy put corn roads in my hair and I did fucking things that
would explain the cows on my knees,
but I'm not going to because it was in a different country and it doesn't
fucking count.
Well,
what I did was look at me with all the fucking energy.
You know what?
I thought I had a meeting this morning at 10 in the morning.
It turns out it was fucking yesterday.
Same clean shaven and I am dressed,
dressed to impress for this fucking podcast.
And,
uh,
anyways,
I've been on the road for the last 10 fucking days.
And,
uh,
I finally got to sleep in my own bed,
saw my girl,
I saw my dog,
you know,
I came home,
I watch some sports yesterday,
even though fucking Red Sox and the Patriots lost,
you know,
good for the angels,
by the way.
All the people out here in California,
man,
good for you guys.
You know,
I know what it's like when you can never beat a team.
Granted,
I wish you still couldn't beat us,
but I know what the fucking deal is.
I watch to pay a fucking red sox lose to the Yankees for the first 80% of my
life without first 36 years of my life could not beat the sons of bitches.
So,
uh,
congratulations to you.
I hope you'll beat the Yankees and uh,
you know,
I really hope you do,
but the fucking Yankees look really good too.
They really do.
There are $200 million team is just plugging away against that $60 million
fucking Minnesota twins.
That's right.
Check.
Can't some bring it up.
But you know why?
Because none of the announcers due to share as having a hell of a bat Jeters
aren't first.
Ah,
Jesus Christ has taken a lead off the third base.
He better watch out.
He's still got that robe on.
It's not even fucking competition anymore.
You know?
And I know the red sox are part of the fucking problem,
but Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ,
really?
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead.
Good luck,
Minnesota.
You really should be up two games to one if you didn't fucking blow it,
you know,
but what do you guys care?
How,
what do you guys care?
You got the mall of America,
he can go down there and ride the Ferris wheel right across from the stride rite
outlet.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
I've been on the fucking road for the last 10 days and I swear to God,
um,
I figured it out in the last three weeks.
I have done 22 sets of an hour or more and I was,
my final night was Saturday night at the Improv in Pittsburgh,
which,
um,
is really becoming one of my favorite cities out there.
Uh,
it's just,
uh,
it's just a great sports city.
It's one of the greatest views when he calls it the Fort Pitt tunnel.
I don't know what it is.
A,
you always come through the tunnel,
right.
You know,
after you drive down the fucking roadway there,
whatever,
when I can't come out of the airport and get on the highway,
there we go.
You know,
the only thing that sucks about Pittsburgh as they're really big on having
whatever the numbers of lanes are,
when you get on the bridge,
there's one less lane.
They're really into that bottleneck thing.
Um,
three lanes that goes down to two,
four goes down to three.
That type of ship when anyways,
when you go through the tunnel,
when you come out,
um,
you think you're just going to be coming,
you know,
up underground like you know,
like the Holland tunnel on the Lincoln tunnel.
When you come into New York City,
feel like a fucking rat.
You just come up and you're right at street level.
But in,
in Pittsburgh you come through like this,
uh,
I don't know if it's big enough to say it's a mountain.
It's a fucking hill.
And they dug a tunnel right through it.
And as you come out,
right as you get to the other side,
the whole city is right out in front of you.
This panoramic view of the whole city and look,
you look to the left is Heinz field where the Steelers play and next to it is
that a,
the ballpark where the AAA pirates play,
where the Yankees and red sox actually have trained vultures circling the
stadium.
And when anybody hits a triple,
we both dive bomb and to see who can snatch the first.
It's a tragedy,
man.
Major League baseball is a fucking tragedy.
You know.
What do you think the red sox are going to do this off season?
$120 million.
All we spent last year,
one 25.
You think we're not going to get back up to a buck 80?
Like we usually do better watch out.
Oh,
you little fucking teams around the league were coming.
We got our checkbook.
Um,
it's horrible.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
Um,
yeah,
the whole,
they have like all these bridges,
all this great steelwork that,
you know,
people actually live in the town if they didn't die when they were building them
falling off the bridge,
cause they had to smoke weed because they were afraid of heights but couldn't
admit it because they're a man.
Um,
all those bridges are there.
And uh,
this is nothing about Pittsburgh.
Very,
very,
very underrated delis.
Whenever you hear about great like Pastrami,
corned beef or whatever,
you always hear,
you know,
go to a New York,
New York Deli.
Oh,
I'll make you fucking hero.
But Pittsburgh,
I dunno what's going on out there,
but for some reason they have kept it a,
why doesn't that guy fee area go there?
You know,
and take a big fucking bite out of that shit cause I'm telling you incredible,
incredible.
A Deli meat.
I went to a Cayman a day early and went to the Pittsburgh penguins verse,
the Phoenix Coyotes,
one of the worst hockey games I've ever been to.
They didn't fucking show up cause they were resting cause they had the flyers
the next night.
Let's just go easy.
They're bankrupt.
We'll just let them win tonight.
That's basically the game I went to.
But it was fun to go to the old thing.
So,
uh,
I'm just babbling.
I'm babbling like a fucking fat chick who just got an engagement rank,
you know,
that's what's going on here.
That was really mean and uncalled for.
Um,
so anyways,
this is what I have to talk.
Do you know what I want to do this week?
I want to take some time out to talk to you guys about what it's like to fly
from fucking Pittsburgh to Los Angeles.
Basically,
there's one show in town and the show's name is us air.
And um,
I went in,
I mean,
you are,
Sarah is,
it's a fucking rinky dink.
Caroline.
Who's kidding?
Who,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
Like if they,
if they were in baseball,
they would be like the pod race,
you know,
no friends to,
you know what I mean?
That in an offensive way.
There's no comedy clubs in San Diego.
W what am I really hurting?
You know?
Um,
this is what I did.
I show up and I go to check in,
um,
and I'm bringing my bag along and uh,
I'm checking a bag.
Basically,
you know how much they want for first checked bag.
Go ahead.
I'll wait.
Take a guess.
What'd you say?
15 [inaudible] higher.
2020.
You say their guy in the back even more.
25 bucks for the first bag checked.
Now do they bring that up?
Is that anywhere on the Internet as you're going to make your fucking die?
I didn't,
I don't know who do I know I fucking,
I call my travel edge at all I know is they don't fucking bring it up until you
get to the airport and then you go to give it to the bag and then they go,
that'll be $25 and they got you.
They got ya.
It's a total fucking shakedown.
And that's the exact song that went through my head cause I was thinking,
why don't you just make this part of the ticket?
You know,
it's kind of like 1995 plus shipping and handling.
So you don't see that it really costs like 27 bucks.
Then you'd be 27 bucks.
That's not worth that onion chopper thing.
If there's a one in the beginning,
I'll definitely fucking buy it.
Right?
That's what they're doing to me.
And I'm tired of it.
Total fucking shake down those fucking cops.
And I say to Lego,
you gotta be kidding me.
It's 25 bucks for the first thing.
She goes,
yeah,
I know,
I know.
She goes,
well it's only 20 if,
if you go on the Internet.
And it's like,
yeah,
and then you don't have a job.
And she goes,
I know I go,
so why would you tell me that?
She goes,
to be honest with you,
the people above us say,
we have to tell people that.
All right.
And we also have to suggest that they use the automated machines.
And I go,
that's unbelievable.
She goes,
yeah,
and you know what?
The people above us get a commission for the amount of people who use the
automated machines and we don't get anything.
Do you realize how fucked up that is?
All you fucking people who argue with me about those automated machines,
do you see what they're doing?
They're pitting us against each other.
People's bad financial positions.
That lady behind the counter,
she wants to keep her job.
So she literally has to teach people how to phase her out of a fucking job.
You know?
I Dunno.
The whole time I was in now all I here,
I kept hearing the Unilad ACDC song,
shakedown,
nervous shake down off of a flick of the switch.
You know how it goes.
You don't,
you don't know how.
You don't know how it goes.
You guys weren't fans of that shit.
Here it is.
Here it is right here.
Yeah,
it's $25 for the first bag.
Yeah.
We didn't tell you because we knew you wouldn't pick this fucking airline.
That's all I heard in my head.
Then I'm on the fucking flight and this old lady goes,
oh,
I'm a little chilly,
sweet little old lady.
Right?
Could I have a blanket in the law?
And the stewardess said,
that'll be $7
[inaudible]
that's what they should have.
That's the song that they should have had this second phase,
close the cabin door.
It's fucking brutal.
$7 $7 for a blanket.
Everybody on us here.
But then somebody told me that's actually because of the swine flu because of
the swine flu.
And I was like,
wait a minute now,
didn't we put small pox in blankets and give them to the Indians?
You know?
So maybe there was something.
I don't know.
I vaguely remember reading that,
that you can wipe out a whole group of people if they're,
if they're cold,
it's very easy to do.
You just put,
you just sneeze on some blankets and you hand it to them and then they start
dropping like flies.
And the ones that survive run a Casino Ronit Casino when they cry about litter.
So see,
there you go.
People.
Okay,
now it gets worse.
So I'm on this fucking plane,
right?
Is 25 bucks.
MMM.
25 bucks for the first bag.
$7 for a blanket.
The people in my row was saying that there's a rumor they're actually going to
start charging for the bathroom,
which I think is bullshit.
There's fucking way.
We're not to that point.
Are We?
Um,
and then when we go to land,
this is the greatest fucking thing ever.
I go to land,
I'm like,
thank God,
thank God I have made it.
I am back here in La.
I'm going to sleep in my own bed and we see my baby and we see my dog.
Everything's going to be gray.
I fucking standard down their foot waiting for the bag that I paid $25 for.
That should come out of the fucking thing on its own little pillow for that
amount of money.
Right.
I had to wait half hour for my bag.
Still nothing.
No one,
not Smith from anybody,
nothing.
So I finally walk into the thing and I'm like,
excuse me,
do you know what's going on here?
She goes,
yeah,
we kind of Sunday we kind of have like a skeleton crew.
So I make a joke,
what do you got?
Like one guy on loading the plane,
she goes,
yeah,
one guy for 200 bags,
you know,
and I don't flip out at those people behind the counter because I know that
their job is to basically sit there and get yelled at by people who don't
understand that they don't make the fucking policy.
Right.
So I leave,
alright,
half hour in,
another 20 minutes goes by,
I'm standing there for almost a fucking hour,
no bag,
and everybody stand around like zombies.
Occasionally somebody would be fucking walking in there.
And,
uh,
I finally walked in there and I was just like,
all right,
um,
I know you don't have anything to do with this policy,
but do you have a form that I can fill out so I can ask for my $25 back please?
And Lily's like,
um,
no,
there's no form for that.
I have a number here.
And I go,
how many people do you have working right now on a Sunday?
And she's like,
I don't know.
I don't have access to that information.
Um,
do you do this every Sunday?
Just so I know in the future when I go to travel that I won't fly us Aaron on a
Sunday.
Do you know,
do you do this every Sunday?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't usually work Sundays.
Do you know what's going on with the bag?
Yeah.
I don't know how to contact the people.
Every fucking thing I asked her,
she couldn't give me a fucking answer and I was like,
do you think this is a smart way to run a business?
I mean I don't have a problem working.
Yeah.
Fucking morons.
So I go just gimme gimme gimme I'm becoming that person.
I fucking complain all the time.
Right.
Um,
I'm gonna,
I got the thing,
I'm going to get my $25 back.
I got to figure out how to do it.
I don't think I'm going to be able to do it via email.
I think I need to get on the phone and I go,
I want money back.
I'm sorry sir.
We don't ask for refunds.
I'm sorry.
I know you're sorry.
You guys are always sorry,
but none of you guys can fucking help.
All right.
I can't curse.
So I realized you're sorry.
I'm sorry to,
is there someone above you that I can speak to?
Well,
I would like to speak to them and just keep going up and up and up and become
such a pain in the ass.
And the key is you don't curse because if you don't curse,
they can't hang up on you.
Yeah.
Well my buddies had a great fucking line the other day.
He was on one of these 1-800-NUMBERS and he was,
and he was having the same problem.
He goes,
yeah,
I,
I want a refund and I'm sorry we don't refunds.
Um,
is there anything else I can help you with?
[inaudible] anything else you can help me with?
You haven't helped me with anything yet.
You fucking Twat.
And of course she hangs up cause he said the f and the t word.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I don't even know what I'm talking about right now.
I think the only fucking way to get back at these corporations is you have to be
like those little old ladies who just won't go away.
And you really just have to complain and just say that it's completely
unacceptable.
I mean,
what the fuck?
Kind of an airline doesn't have enough guys to unload their fucking airplane.
You know,
I love too is such a jam packed fucking airplane.
And I know it's a tough time.
I didn't know they're probably even losing money,
but those fucking assholes at the top are still make it just as much money,
just as much money as they were.
A guarantee at those fucking CEO,
CEO douchebags never take any,
they never take a fucking pay cut.
They got me standing down there for an extra fucking hour.
Did I say I was in a good mood this week?
I actually am in a good mood,
but um,
I'm more pissed off at the fucking people who challenged me on those automated
things and all that.
You don't even realize you're leading yourself and the rest of us down this
fucking path and that's what it's going to be in the future.
There's going to be nobody there and there's going to be one robocop and if the
second you start complaining,
they're going to somehow connect the dots with you when the al Qaeda and you're
going to get shot.
All right?
Maybe that's,
maybe that's a little bit of an exaggeration,
but you know what I mean.
Whatever happened to the customer is always right.
Fucking old lady next to me.
She was,
she put newspaper on her legs.
I don't fucking know what,
what,
what are you going to do?
All right,
let's,
let's move on with the podcast.
And if you like that song,
nervous shakedown,
which I don't know why you wouldn't,
you know,
why wouldn't you like that?
Why does that sound good?
Dat,
dat,
dat about Abu.
Um,
all right,
let's get on with the podcast.
So if you knew my podcast,
um,
most times I'm in a country mood and sometimes I say I'm in a good mood and I
still sound a little bit cunty.
Um,
last week a lot of people really enjoyed,
um,
when Joe de Rosa was a guest hosting cohosting was being,
uh,
Joe McMahon and uh,
we got a big debate over what was less healthy doughnuts or pancakes and a,
I was on the pancake side and everybody seemed to agree with me and one person
actually sent me a little linked to show how donuts are made after they make the
dough and all that.
Evidently they fucking deep fry them for like seven days before they even add
the jelly and the,
and the,
and the guru and the coconut and the crap that they put on them.
And fucking Joe to Rosa is trying to tell me that Bisquick some eggs and some
butter and a little bit of Syrup is,
is,
is worse than that.
I don't know the Syrup Mai Tai.
It's,
it's,
it's damn close.
In order to like,
this is what it's like pancakes or the red sox and donuts at the Yankees.
You know,
it's basically the difference.
Probably 180 million and 200 million.
Um,
oh look at that.
I got an email from the ACDC official store.
I'm 41.
Let's see what they have to say.
Oh,
they have a limited edition ACDC tee shirt.
That's actually fucking cool.
They wrote ACDC on like a Marshall amp preorder the ACDC backtracks two CD.
Oh Wow.
They're getting fucking old.
Remember they used to say that they never fucking release shit.
Rerelease material.
They don't like doing it.
The ACDC backtracks amplifier tee shirt.
What is going on?
Let me get back to the podcast and I'm fucking look at this later.
All right.
We've got a lot of shit to get to.
Cause last week I shot the shit with Joe to Rosa and,
um,
I didn't get a chance to answer a lot of questions or whatever.
One of one of the people actually had a great solution.
Remember last member a couple of weeks ago on a,
on,
I read that,
um,
I read that story where that that guy was flicking the ear of the boyfriend of
a,
of a sister,
you know,
and they were a little drunk.
They would come from the cubs game.
I'll do a little recap here.
And the,
the,
the boyfriend was driving,
telling the dude to stop and he kept fucking doing it.
And then the kid just snapped and he turned around and punched him in the face
and knocked his teeth out.
So the brother of the sister,
um,
says,
now I have to kick the shit out of that kid and it has to happen.
The kids been ducking me and I know I'm going to do it,
but,
um,
I just need you to help me explain it to my sister,
why it has to happen.
So I offered a,
Oh yeah,
that was last week.
That was last week.
See,
10 days on the road,
you don't even know when the fuck it was.
It was last week.
So me and Joe de Rosa tried to give this guy some solutions and I hope he's
still listening this week and he didn't get pissed off.
But,
uh,
this guy has got a great ear flick solution.
All right.
He says,
Bill,
I have a great way to resolve the fight between the two friends in the last
week's podcast.
Two words,
flare,
chop.
All right.
For all your rent,
raw wrestling fans out there are originated by the nature boy ric flair.
You simply,
you simply wind up and backhand the person in the chest.
My cousin,
brother,
and I use it to resolve all arguments between us.
The reason it's effective is that hurts like a bitch,
but only for a short period of time.
It's hilarious for all that.
Watch it and leaves the raised imprint on the person's chest.
After you flare chop someone all malcontent melts away.
I think that's a fucking hilarious,
hilarious idea.
So all you gotta do,
explain to your sister what the flare chop is.
And,
uh,
I think that's perfect because it's not going to be anything permanent.
I think it's going to get away.
A lot of anger is going to get out.
You can,
you guys can start over and uh,
cause whose kitten heel?
You know,
I'd rather have my ear flicked and get my tooth knocked out,
but you were kind of being a cunt.
So this is a great way to resolve it and it's fucking hilarious.
Maybe you can turn it into a funny youtube video and I'll probably get a lot of
hits.
So my hat is off to that wonderful fucking solution.
They should give you one of those judge shows.
I think you really got a really got a knack for it to flare.
Chop the nature boy ric flair.
All right,
here's something else.
Somebody sent me this week and um,
I dunno,
I didn't really fit into the advice.
It didn't really fit into questions,
but I thought it was a great point.
So this is kind of an op ed piece.
Um,
all right.
It says,
dear bill,
this past week,
I attended game one of the series between the Dodgers and the cardinals.
Uh,
before the game started there was of course the national anthem.
They Gab,
they gathered,
uh,
let me move this closer to my eyeballs so I can read this.
They gathered probably 50 to 75 or so sailors from the u s navy locally based
and they hurled out this huge flag.
Um,
fast forward to about the fifth inning when they are doing the cheesy jumbo tron
spotlight and they put the troops up on the screen,
everyone in the stadium,
cheers and applauds.
That's when I noticed that they had these navy guy where they had these navy
guys seated.
They were seated in the very top section in the nosebleeds.
This is just bullshit to me.
We say we love our troops and they had the greatest citizens yet we can't afford
to upgrade them to at least the outfield or even the second level fuck the MLB
for using the troops as a way to show their corporate patriotism and then
sticking them at the very top of the state.
Is it really that much to ask for an organization such as the MLB or the
Dodgers?
Who am I?
Who am whomever the decision is up to to lose just a little bit of money.
Um,
on some seats.
The right field bleachers were not even sold out.
Fucking ungrateful,
fake patriotic cuts.
Um,
I don't know about you guys,
but I thought he made some great points there.
I've seen that a lot of times they do.
Whenever there's a large group of people be at the troops or some inner city
kids,
the,
you know,
they always fucking stick them all the way up at the top of the stadium.
Uh,
you know,
that's,
that's capitalism for you.
You would think though,
you know what I mean?
You would think with the troops,
the least they could do.
Yeah.
Stick them on the,
there it's stick them on the mezzanine level.
You know what I mean?
I may look a team like the Yankees.
I mean those,
those seats around,
who's kidding,
who those things are like 1500 a whack.
There's no fucking way you could do that.
Um,
so yeah,
stick them on the middle level.
I think that's decent,
right?
A lot of this shit around the uh,
around home plate.
Those are season tickets.
Yeah.
Maybe they could do that.
They could actually have those corporate cons and some of those rich bastards
who have season tickets give away their tickets for one night.
Maybe they do a nice little switch.
That'd be a great little thing as a thank you.
You know,
they switched seats,
they let him sit down there and then the corporate guys could pat themselves on
the back of what great people they are as they fucking trudge their way up to
the top and look down on all of us the way they've always wanted to.
All right,
now let's move on to the next section.
This is getting really choppy.
I'm trying to think of anything interesting happening.
Anything interesting.
That's something me and my girlfriend always talk about.
You remember that bugs bunny cartoon where a,
you know the monster that actually had arms but you couldn't see him.
He wore the chuck Taylor high tops.
He was all brown and all the hair.
And you remember that time when bugs bunny just sat him down and started doing
his nails and doing his hair going month.
There's such interesting,
people must be so interested in Gbm onstar.
Do you remember that?
Um,
do you know?
I didn't think so.
All right.
What happened?
This I just lost all momentum.
I was doing so fucking well,
I don't give a shit.
I'm psyched to be home.
I'm really psyched to be home.
And if you have a pit bull,
you really have to watch out for their head because it's like a fucking bowling
ball.
And when they get excited,
they swing that thing around.
It's going to catch in your chops,
it's going to hit you in the throat and a,
you're gonna have to lay on the ground for a minute and then they're going to
come up with that paintbrush sized fucking tongue and practically drown you with
it.
So,
um,
if you're thinking about getting,
getting a pit bull when you come home after not seeing it for 10 days,
you really,
you gotta Kinda,
I,
I come from behind and what I do is I make sure I have my head away from its
head.
Even if you get it to the side,
it's like a fucking alligator.
Just swings it around.
MMM.
I Dunno.
Things a maniac.
Okay.
All right,
let's go.
Okay.
Interpreting dreams.
Um,
this is like a new segment that I thought it was going to be great and it never
really took off.
Uh,
here's a dream that somebody has.
Okay.
Bill,
last night I dreamt that there,
oh,
last night I had a dream that was so damn weird on so many levels.
Basically I was back in the early eighties.
I was born in 1990.
Okay,
so he's born in 1990 for yet,
for some reason he's in the 1980s.
I mean,
I might need some help on this one.
Um,
and there were,
they were gangs all around where I used to live in Reno,
Nevada.
It was almost exactly like that movie,
the warriors.
But I'd never in my life
till today seen that movie.
I didn't really think much of it till I watched a movie this morning and I swear
to fucking God that was so similar to the dream I had.
It weirded me out to the point that I'm pretty sure I just failed a biology test
today at school because all I could think about was the damn dream.
Just the fact that I basically dream something that had already been created and
then I had just heard they are making a remake is pretty fucking strange.
Any thoughts?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I think you've been working out and you really want to wear a vest with no shirt
underneath it and a,
you just grew up in a generation where that's unacceptable on all fucking
levels,
even during Halloween.
So,
uh,
in your dream you were wishing that you were born during a time when a way you
could,
where you could wear a fucking leather vest without a shirt underneath it.
You know,
maybe join a gang,
maybe sing some doo-wop around a burning trashcan.
I think that's what your dream meant.
It means that,
you know what I think it is.
You were born in 1990.
I bet in your past life you are actually a member of a,
of a,
of a gang,
you know,
as opposed to some regular kid who just goes to college out in fucking Reno and
is bored shitless with his life.
Right.
So he jerks off to porn on the Internet.
Isn't any,
any of this,
you know,
I'm going to do is I'm going to parachute out of this fucking business.
This is where I'm going to do right now.
Okay?
I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to do one of those.
What are those?
What are those fucking chicks who look like men who tell your future?
You know,
they get the little snow globe in front of them where they take the dandruff out
of it and then all of a sudden they can see your future.
This is what they do.
They get a little,
they get a little information about you and uh,
next thing you know,
they just start piecing some shit together.
There you go.
I should put on some gypsy scarf right now.
That's right.
In your past life you were the member of a gang and uh,
you know,
you've got,
you've got fucking stabbed to death and uh,
he had plans,
he had plans to bring all the gangs together.
That's what the fuck you wanted to do.
And you're the guy who got shot by fucking Cyrus.
Was that his name?
That's what it is.
You wish you were born in a different era as opposed to now where you live this
very safe life.
You want to be a road warrior and you can't,
what's the matter?
Was there some girl you wanted to talk to but you didn't have the balls to,
you know,
so when your dreams,
you're trying to become like this hard ass,
I guess you weren't in a drain.
You weren't in a gang and your dream,
I don't fucking know.
I Dunno.
Send me more dreams.
I'll get better at it.
You know what?
Maybe why.
That's why that segment didn't take off.
All right,
let's get back to something a little more proven.
This is like,
don't stand up right now.
That was like a new bit.
It bombed.
And I'm going to go to a proven joke that I've told 600 times and make it sound
brand new.
All right,
here we go.
Advice Bill.
Uh,
I recently got dumped by my girlfriend,
um,
through behaving like an idiot.
To be honest in her shoes.
I would have done the same thing with the difference that I would have given.
I would have given me a second chance for the record.
No,
I didn't cheat on her.
Instead,
I found myself getting quite broody.
I think that means depressed,
uh,
with all the heaviness that goes with that.
Um,
who knew that that can happen to men too?
I certainly didn't.
What does broody mean?
What does it mean to be brooding?
Isn't that what's his face did and rumble fish,
Matt Dillon.
Isn't that how he got out?
He got all his,
his,
uh,
his acting work.
They used to always say he had the,
the brooding good looks.
So what happened?
You'd be in the apartment with your girlfriend,
she'd be trying to talk to you and you'd be leaned up against one wall.
You know,
one foot on the floor of the other one up against the wall and she'd be like,
what do you want for breakfast?
And then just sort of look,
you know,
he looked to the sat,
I don't know,
just doesn't feel right.
Did you have a cigarette pack rolled up in your tee shirt?
What the fuck is broody?
I don't know what that is.
Anyway,
see,
uh,
she goes,
um,
he goes,
I believe
I'm through that madness now and yet while I was only with her for about three
months,
I miss her companionship terribly.
I think he means he was depressed.
Anyways,
he goes,
I sent her some flowers to say I was sorry,
but she says she doesn't want to see or talk with me,
although she says she will contact me in the future when some other,
other heavy shit she's going through right now is over.
Um,
I feel I owe the situation one last roll of the dice at the very least.
Do you have any suggestions?
Yeah.
You guys need to not be near each other.
All right.
First of all,
if you want her to call you back,
don't call her,
all right?
Because you're going to sound even more brooding is you're standing there crying
with a bouquet of flowers or whatever,
whatever the fuck you going through.
And then this whole thing was,
she says she'll contact you in the future when some heavy shit she's going
through right now is over with.
You know,
I'm thinking of that movie.
Barfly you guys both like alcoholics.
What does the heavy shit,
she's got to get through the fucking 12 pound meat hammer.
She's going to be riding tonight.
I'm not trying to be a dick,
but,
um,
look,
well,
you got to do right now,
okay?
If you're out there Bruning and you're all depressed,
you're probably not coming across as someone she wants to mate with.
Who's going to bring her some strong offspring,
okay?
To get all discovery channel on you.
So what you gotta do is you've got to show her that you're a man.
So what you gotta do is just let her go.
All right?
It start going to the fucking gym.
Getting eight hours sleep.
He started eating right.
You Start and you can make yourself look good.
You make improvements in your own life.
So the next time she sees you,
if you run into are you look great.
All right.
What was that fucking Rodney danger,
danger field thing.
What was that movie where they're doing the Cyrano de Bergerac Shit.
Remember that Chico Telia and the man remember that?
That's what you gotta do next time she sees you.
You're the fucking confident.
Nah,
that's bad advice.
What are you gonna pretend to be confident?
I don't know.
I'm just saying you know what?
To focus on yourself.
Get your own shit together.
You know,
and don't wait for her to call you.
start working out eating right,
getting some sleep.
Go do some shit.
You always wanted to fucking do,
you know,
and go out to the,
go out to clubs.
Start talking to girls who are quote on quote way out of your league.
See what,
see what the fuck happens.
You know?
But the last thing you want to do right now,
I swear to God,
is to sit around thinking about that girl or calling her or sending her flowers
in a box of chocolates and all that shit because,
uh,
you know,
she needs a break from,
yeah,
I think,
and granted,
once again,
I give out this advice knowing that I didn't really go to college.
I did,
but it doesn't really count.
And I have no background whatsoever and I know fucking read.
So you're on your own.
If you take my advice,
I take no responsibility for this shit whatsoever.
All right.
And not to mention this,
a zillion fucking chicks out there.
Why don't you go join one of those dating services?
That's a great fucking way to get laid.
You know,
someone was talking to me about that the other day,
you know,
there's like two of them.
One of them's about really getting into a relationship and the other one's just
about fucking join the one that's just about fucking and uh,
go by.
Go down a Bj's wholesale and get some condoms and bang away.
All right?
But the last thing you want to do is to get all fucking depressed about this
shit and waste another couple months of your life brooding.
Alright.
Dust yourself off.
Get back in the game.
All right.
All right,
next one.
Hey Bill.
Uh,
I've got an interesting uh,
situation going on.
I've been really good friends with this guy friend.
I'll do this is a,
this is a fucking great question.
I don't even know if I can answer this one,
so I'm going to need some help.
All right.
Uh,
hey bill.
I got a,
an interesting situation going on.
I've been really good friends with this guy friend of mindful for like four
years.
We're super tight.
Talk all the time.
Say I love you regularly finish each other's sentences,
that sort of crap.
Well,
one day I call them and found out that he had stopped mid hookup with a girl to
answer my phone call.
When I asked why,
he said it was because I was the most important girl in the world to him right
in front of the girl he was getting play from.
Yeah.
My question to you is,
does this do dig me or is he just a great friend?
And if he does,
why has any ever made a move?
Ah,
wow.
Wow.
Okay.
All
right.
There we go.
It's not an original fucking question in a way,
but it is because this is what two dudes now.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ had a fuck.
Do I answer this one?
Uh,
yeah.
Joel,
there's something fucking going on there.
The way you write about it.
It sounds like you're in a relationship.
You guys are in a relationship.
It sounds like a,
yeah.
I don't know what his deal is.
He's definitely curious.
I can tell you that.
Uh,
I dunno,
I,
I've never tried to figure out if a dude like me like that,
but this is really making me uncomfortable.
That's why I liked this fucking question.
Um,
yeah,
I think you got to figure out what's going,
you know,
but I,
I gotta be honest with you if this will,
yeah,
I'll give you the same advice that if you will,
if this was like a woman and she keeps acting like that around you,
but she's hooking up with some other guy,
then I'd be like fuck or walk away.
So I'll give you the same advice.
Fuck this dude.
He hasn't,
you know,
if he is gay,
he's not ready to admit it yet.
And what are you going to do?
Stand around like some fucking,
uh,
some fucking guy who stands around fuck dead.
Go down to a fiddle sticks,
whatever,
whatever the fuck they was actually a gay bar called that.
I remember there was a standup Gig in Boston.
Someone of my friends did it.
It's called,
it's called fiddlesticks.
Um,
yeah,
fuck debt.
Yeah.
Got Out of the bar.
Do what you guys do.
Work Out,
get the fucking abs going.
Put on a tight shirt.
Just don't hook up with a creepy older guy.
That's something I noticed when it living in New York,
in La,
there's always like a creepy older guy with the young,
younger gay dude.
Like he's teaching them how to be gay or something and they're like gold drink,
dig and gay guys out there.
Cause I really don't want,
cause guys are visual fucking people.
You know what I mean?
So I,
I don't know how the fuck that goes down and I'll tell you right now,
I don't want to,
so whatever do,
I don't know what your deal is.
Confront him or fucking move on.
Cause uh,
you know,
if he actually is gay and he's still out there banging women,
uh,
you know when I'm telling you you're only on earth for a very short period of
time,
your time is valuable.
You got to put a value on it just like that guy before you.
Okay.
They're check fucking took off.
Now he's standing there walking around trying to hand her flowers.
She's still giving him the Heisman.
And then that's when you gotta be like,
that's when you,
you got to get some fucking self esteem and be like,
look,
I'm better than this.
I'm the shit.
I'm telling you the solutions,
you always go to the gym.
He listened to some fucking music.
That's how I do it.
You know,
if I can get some sleep,
you start looking good,
you feel good about yourself and then you go out and you talk to somebody who
really,
you have no business talking to and they shoot you down.
Then you have a couple more drinks and you start thinking about the person that
made you want to do that in the first place and you go back into the depression,
but you wake up the next day and you do it over again.
It's six weeks people,
six weeks.
You've got to tough it out for six fucking weeks and you'll get out of it.
So good luck to the both of you.
All right,
next question.
Hey Bill,
this a hockey question.
Um,
it's another reason why I'm saying to you back on the road is now I can finally
actually watch some hockey games ordering the NHL package today.
Much to my girlfriend's Chagrin,
um,
hockey question.
Hey,
bill,
you seem to be a knowledgeable person when it comes to hockey.
So I figure,
uh,
it would be best to ask you,
um,
being that I live in New Orleans where there's no hint of an organized hockey
and very few televised game,
I am very limited on my knowledge of the sport even though I love it.
I basically,
I basically cheer for Detroit,
the Kings,
the avalanche,
the devils,
and the mighty ducks.
All right?
You can tell you don't know a lot about hockey if you chew,
if you root for both the Redwings and the avalanche,
that's like rooting for the buckeyes and the Wolverines,
the red sox and the Yankees,
the Longhorns,
and the sooner you know,
the troops and the al Qaeda,
the different sides.
Do you got to pick a side on that one?
Anyways,
let's get to his question.
Now my question is,
what is wrong with the mighty ducks?
Why are they not considered a respectable team?
I went to a buddy's house to watch a hockey game this weekend and was basically
booed.
That's funny.
You get booed and delivering on boot into oblivion because I was wearing a
duck's jersey in parentheses because it's the only one I own.
I was told by him as well as the seven other people president at the reason for
hating the ducks was,
has nothing to do with the way they play,
but rather it's the fact that the ducks are not a real team.
Is this a general feeling amongst real hockey fans?
Uh,
or am I just dealing with some bonehead friends?
Let me know and thanks in advance.
All right.
This is the deal.
Um,
I don't know how old you are,
but do you remember the mighty ducks was a movie was a Disney movie starring
Emilio Estefan as [inaudible],
however the fuck you say his name,
and it was a kid movie.
It was basically the bad news bears on ice,
which is,
was very,
I mean,
the worst fucking collection of kids.
Emilio Estefan has probably had relationship problems and he learned a lot about
himself while working with the kids.
And then for some reason there's this unbelievable hottie who's really into the
fucking kids and see something in him that he didn't know happen.
And then they hook up and then somewhere along the line they have a big fight
and then he has to get her back.
And meanwhile there's some big hockey game.
And uh,
I imagine the coach of the other team,
Emilio Estefan is already fucking knows on some level.
And that dude always wins in life.
And now this is his chance.
You know what?
I bet the coach from the other team is dating that hot girl and then they hook
up.
Is that how it works?
Is that how the movie was?
I can never watch it.
Cause by the time it came out I was like fucking 25 years old.
Yes,
I'm that fucking old.
So anyways,
yeah,
the team.
So the movie was,
I evidently a big hit.
They made like two or three of them.
And along the way,
Disney bought a hockey team.
And because of the corporate cunt mentality,
they named it the mighty ducks.
Okay.
That's the,
the history of that team.
Now,
the NHL,
the history of the NHL is,
it used to be six teams and six of the angriest,
most psychotic fucking cities in North America fighting was legal.
You smashed,
sticks over people's heads,
you know,
Teddy Green had to get a plate and his fucking head,
it's a maniac fucking sport.
And then they show up like high were those Ma,
where are the mighty dark play?
Some up fuckers.
It's already difficult when you have this many teams because they really are out
of ferocious animals to name teams after.
So,
um,
now they're kind of naming them after different kinds of weather or general as
you know,
like,
uh,
the storm,
the thunder,
the lightning,
the cold front and on the fucking,
you know what I mean?
Or they categorize the predators.
I still don't know what a thrasher is.
What is a thrasher?
That's a kind of metal speed metal,
right.
Anyways,
so anyways,
that's why people,
they don't like the ducks because,
um,
hockey is like a rogue sport.
And,
um,
it's never been accepted,
accepted by the mainstream,
nor will it ever.
And uh,
then all of a sudden they came in with the mighty ducks and a,
they really left themselves wide open.
But the thing about they got rid of the mighty,
so now they're just called the ducks.
And the,
the funny thing about the ducks is the kind of hockey that they play.
They play like a really physical in your face.
Like I,
I love the style of hockey that they play and I even know they just traded
fucking Chris [inaudible].
Um,
you know,
I gotta admit I'm starting to like the Philadelphia flyers because there's
something about them that I can relate to in my life.
And that's the fact that in the mid seventies,
they won two Stanley cups by beating the shit out of people.
Okay.
That's not what I'm relating to.
But they had an angle that was successful and since then they have failed
miserably with the whole,
we're gonna beat the shit out of you to win a Stanley Cup.
But God damn it,
it doesn't stay,
have not diverted from that game plan one iota since 1974 75 they are still
trying to,
even though the league has changed completely,
they are still trying to beat the shit out of people.
And you know,
they added Chris pronger cause they think this is why we're going to be able to
compete against the fucking capitals and the Pittsburgh Penguins.
And what are they?
Do they,
they,
they fucking lose six to five and then they have a big fight at the end.
And I relate to that because I have certain things in my life that I've been
trying to solve with the exact same approach.
And I fail every fucking time,
but I for some reason can't get out of this Rut.
So,
um,
I'm getting the NHL package today and I'm telling you,
if you want to get into hockey,
watch the penguins,
flyers,
games all this year,
there's not going to be one boring one.
Um,
and a lot of people don't like when I talk about sports,
but I don't give a fuck.
I gotta tell you,
I'm concerned about my Bruins.
I don't know why they traded Phil Kessel.
I don't get it.
Why you would trade a young guy who's your number one goal score and you trade
them for draft picks.
I could see if he was 35 and he was past his prime,
then you're like,
hey,
we gotta get young.
But so many draft picks,
they don't,
they turn out to be nothing.
And you actually had a young guy who scored like 39 fucking goals and he missed
some games last year,
man.
Stupid fucking stupid.
And I like it.
I don't like it.
All right,
so there you go.
Do,
that's why they don't like the duck.
So fuck them.
Just learn a little bit more about hockey then you won't say things like,
I'm an I like the Redwings and the avalanche.
Uh,
but good for your man.
Good for you.
Like in hockey down there in New Orleans.
All right,
next question.
Hey Bill.
Um,
I mean a little bit of a dilemma.
I'm 35 years old and I have a 30 year old said,
oh Jesus Christ.
I'm reading the one from last year.
Am I all out of,
did I scroll down too far?
I thought I had some questions here.
Oh,
there's the questions.
All right,
here's some questions then.
I'm going to end the podcast here.
Um,
oh wait a second.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Questions Bill.
If your family,
siblings,
parents and close friends are turning into zombies,
um,
then you could kill them.
I mean,
like totally kill them because if they zombies they wouldn't,
they would technically be dead also.
In addition to that,
uh,
would you have to kill you?
Would you have to kill them in a special way because they are special to you?
Like a quick death bullet to the head or would you just take a baseball bat to
them?
Would you look forward to it?
Um,
I know I'd love it if someone I didn't like became a Zombie so I could have a
legitimate excuse for killing them and getting away with it.
Yes.
Some people I'd love to take my time with.
Okay.
That's a fucked up question.
All right.
He's basically asking me if my all my friends and loved ones turned into
zombies,
could eat what I kill them.
Um,
all right.
In the old days when zombies could just walk slowly,
I would run away from them.
And unless cornered,
like in the Michael Jackson Thriller Villi Video,
obviously yes,
I would kill them rather than sitting there getting eaten alive.
Now with today's Zombie 2.0 uh,
where they can run and that type of shit,
uh,
without a doubt,
yes,
I would kill him cause it isn't them anymore.
And uh,
I want to live and what I do at quickly,
I try to do a quickly,
but if I didn't have anything,
if I only had something that would go slowly,
then I would use something that would go slowly.
You know,
I don't know.
You know what?
I was actually on the road and I saw that,
that Zombie movie,
what does that one,
uh,
Zombie land or something like that.
And I don't know,
cause I wasn't in a crowded movie theater.
I was a little,
little,
little disappointed,
but I heard this something out there.
This,
this new ghost movie called like photosynthesis or something paranormal.
Evidently it's supposed to be the scariest movie of the last 10 years and I'm
going to go see it before somebody fucking ruins it for me.
Um,
so with that,
that is a podcast for this week.
Um,
please try to avoid us air if you can.
American Airlines is also another,
um,
airline that,
that is also $25 a bag.
And,
um,
I'm going to complain and I would like to encourage all of you because they
really put you in this position where you feel like there's nothing you can do.
I think that a regular customers really need to get more vocal.
This is just my opinion.
I'm not getting preachy here,
but,
um,
I really see no end to these greedy cons.
Just taken another bite out of your ass until we pushed back a little bit.
So,
um,
next time you get fucked over,
asked for a website,
send some emails,
do whatever the fuck you can.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck to do.
I'm really,
um,
I don't know what,
so what you don't want me to do right now?
I'm going to thank you.
Everyone who came out to see me over the last six weeks.
Okay.
From,
from Stockholm to Boston to Philly,
all the people in Addison who came out to see me,
um,
all the people that distress factory in New Jersey who've been coming out to see
me for years and in Pittsburgh,
which all of a sudden,
man,
I mean that's a really hard ticket for Comedians to sell out.
They're sold out two shows and the other two shows where all the way to like
literally the last row and um,
you know,
it's seriously,
man,
no jokes here.
It's,
it's,
it's an unbelievable feeling.
You know,
I worked 17 years to get to this point to actually have people like my comedy,
the way you guys do and to come out to my shows is fucking awesome.
And I got to met,
there's always a little bit of panic every time I walk into a showroom where I'm
like,
fuck,
is this the week where there everybody's over me?
And it goes back to 25 fucking people,
you know.
So,
um,
that's it.
Thank you for keeping the dream alive for another fucking week.
And,
um,
and I think,
I think that's it.
And,
uh,
I also wanna thank uh,
Jim and Randy at wd VIII in Pittsburgh for hooking me up with the unbelievable
corn beef sandwiches.
And let me run my mouth on your great radio show,
the OPN Anthony show.
Uh,
who the fuck else I got to start thinking those radio shows cause those guys
really fucking really helped me out.
And uh,
um,
and also,
I want to thank everybody who came out for the,
I got a bit of buddy of mine who's,
who's,
um,
he's really battling sickness right now.
And uh,
I went up and did a benefit of giggles,
which is a great comedy club if you live up in the Boston area.
Um,
my Clark Linny Clark's brother runs it and we did this great benefit for this
comedian Kevin Knox,
just one of the great fucking comedians.
I'll tell you a quick story.
I started in this business in 1992 and one I did,
it was basically at the end of the 1980s a comedy boom.
It was almost like the housing market or the,
uh,
Internet bubble in that there was a bunch of people making way more money than
they should have been and there had to be a correction in the market.
So basically I started in 1992 and when I was working during the first couple
years of my career,
I worked with a lot of guys who used to be making way more money and used to be
headlining.
Um,
sort of the guys like the B and c level headliners.
All right.
And I gotta tell you,
there was a number of them who I will say we're not so nice to work with.
Basically,
they tried to discourage me from being a comedian.
You know,
I'm not talking about the big guns.
The big guns who were in Boston still were drawn and they were still doing well.
But there was like,
there was some B and c level guys that I ran into when they would say shit like,
you know,
you'd be there on like a Thursday or a Wednesday night gig and they'd be like,
fucking 30 people in the crowd.
40 people and they,
they'd be the gold.
Look at this shit man.
Y'All tell you man,
two fucking years ago,
three years ago,
they would have been a line around the block.
You know,
I'll tell you,
man,
if I was your age,
I wouldn't even get into this shit.
You know,
I'd quit right now,
man,
if I was your age,
if I could do this over again and never would had done it yet.
And I sort of guy used to live there with like a gun in my mouth,
you know.
But um,
you know,
there was this one comic,
this Guy Kevin Knox,
I used to go down to his show and he was just a fucking great guy and he would
absolutely,
you know,
just,
just a fucking great guy.
Totally encourage you.
Positive guy.
Not a,
not a jealous bone,
not an envious phone.
Competitive.
None of that shit just to fucking great dude.
And me and all my buddies used to go down and he put us up on his show.
And,
uh,
not only was he great guy,
I really learned how to follow somebody or attempt to follow somebody because
this guy was so fucking funny.
You know,
when he hosted a show,
we used to joke that he didn't host a show.
He used to take breaks from killing cause that's what he would do.
He'd go up and he would just be killing and then I'd be like,
all right,
I'm going to bring up your next act.
And then,
you know,
he'd bring up a fucking 23 year old me and I'd be,
I'd have to go up there and hang on for dear life.
And it really helped me out when I went down to New York and I had to go on
after like,
you know,
I go on after guy who had his own TV show and you know,
the nervousness of that when you first start out being a comedian.
Um,
and I was a much better common cause,
uh,
cause he gave me,
you know,
the opportunity to like,
be on shows and stuff.
And uh,
so anyways,
we had a big benefit for them
up in Boston and giggles comedy club and it was a huge success.
And uh,
you know,
he's battling some shit right now.
So my prayers are going out to them.
And a,
I want to thank my Clark for having that great benefit.
Let me come up being a part of it.
It really,
one of the great nights in my career was just a fucking awesome night.
It was great to see all the guys and seeing a long time.
So,
uh,
that is it.
That is it for the podcast this week.
Um,
thank you everybody for listening.
Please keep sending your questions.
I am off this week.
I'm not doing shit and uh,
what do I got next?
I got coming up,
I got the uh,
Improv in DC.
Um,
I ain't know the fucking dates.
You know what?
Why don't I get more organized Improv in DC.
I know,
actually,
I know one date that I can actually hype.
Right now I have,
I'm playing town hall in New York City,
which is a,
a,
it's a huge date for me,
um,
to play a theater date in New York City.
And that's going to be on,
what the fuck is it?
[inaudible] November six 2009.
All right.
I'm going to be a town hall in New York City.
Tickets are going fast,
everybody.
All right.
Last I checked is only a couple hundred left and uh,
I have all the information up on bill bird.com.
B,
u.
R.
Um,
if you never been to New York City,
it's a great excuse to go down there.
Um,
you basically,
you want to be watching my next standup special live that be taping the next
month in San Francisco,
uh,
cause I got to set or to down and all I gotta do is just keep doing it.
So I really appreciate it if you'd come out and support me.
Okay.
There's a date I'll be playing the Improv in Washington DC.
Um,
October 22nd,
23rd and 24th.
MMM.
Improv in Tempe,
Arizona.
I got hilarides and Cleveland coming up,
giggles in Seattle,
and then that's it.
And then I take my special.
So these shows are all very important to me.
Please come on out.
I'll be selling my DVDs afterwards.
Makes a great stocking stuffer,
and plus we get that person.
It's such a,
it's just a great gift to get somebody.
You don't have to buy mine by another convenience fucking DVD,
but it's a great fucking thing,
you know,
for that,
that that person on your list where you just like,
yeah,
God,
do I gotta to get this fucking person something,
you know,
20 bucks,
bing,
Bang,
boom,
you're fucking done.
Throw it at them.
Make sure the corner hits him right in the side of the fucking head,
Mary Goddamn Christmas.
And that is that.
That's a podcast for this week.
Once again,
thanks for everybody for listening and I will talk to you guys again next
Monday.
Have a great week.
All right,
bye.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].